après trois ans de travaux voici les
nouveaux bâtiments de santé mentale de
l'institut mgen de la verrière
opérationnel depuis un mois près de 200
adolescents jeunes adultes et adultes
ils sont accueillis sur ce même site de
12 hectares un ehpad ou encore une unité
de soins palliatifs verront le jour
début 2000 vingt deux établissements
historiques sont regroupés le centre de
santé mentale marcel rivière et le
centre gériatrique denis forestier on a
souhaité tout regrouper sur un même site
pour pouvoir aussi avoir une prise en
charge dans le même esprit un peu
l'esprit village c'est à dire que tous
les tous les services se travaille
ensemble également et avec avec une
prise en charge le plus optimisée pour
nos patients à nos résidents tout paul
confondues l'institut mgen propose 480
de singly soit 20% de plus qu'avant il
s'agit du site le plus important en
france en termes de capacité d'accueil
les patients qui viennent ici sont
adressés par les professionnels de santé
du territoire
80 % ne sont pas mutualistes c'est une
réponse pour la population de proximité
la population des dix villes mais aussi
d'île de france
la particularité du côté du projet santé
mentale c'est que toutes les unités sont
18es ressources spécialisées pour les
autres secteurs pour les collègues qui
travaillent sur le territoire
nous sommes spécialisés dans la
psychiatrie la personne âgée dans la
psychiatrie de l'adolescent et du jeune
adulte dans la mythologie ou dans la
post urgence par exemple vue sur le
château de la verrière ou encore jardin
protégé permettent un meilleur cadre de
vie aux patients en tout 35 mille mètres
carrés ont été reconstruits
investissements pour ce projet médical
100 millions d'euros